on this episode the legend Sasha
Vaynerchuk stops by
[Music]
[Music]
you ask questions
[Music]
this is
Carrie be everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 254 of
the askgaryvee show and this is a very
very very special episode because the
all-time most popular guest of my
original video and podcast show back in
the day Wine Library TV was none other
than my dad Sasha Vaynerchuk who is here
looking dapper dad yeah well you throw
up a deuce there like that and and who
is now making his second appearance on
the askgaryvee show we got very Orca
yeah we've literally got emotional up in
the Andy was there we were playing
basketball we the screen at the Sephora
what else he remembers that anybody
wanted you this guy's on it Wow I'm
going for us Andy's very impressive can
you set it to me was yeah it's a real
good one yeah well uh so but to
somewhere in New York I didn't realize
this first fun the first time you're in
office right we've been here for almost
a year right
he decided not to show up and say hello
you're busy I was the I wasn't there
I'll tell you a story about didn't busy
okay you had a podcast with Brandon fine
Tyler yes and a friend of mine longtime
friend in the liquor industry in the
wine industry liquor spirit Neil born F
we know I know me well sometimes friends
sometimes animals oh yeah we can meet
you think you've gone years without
talking right that is not how people
normally categorize a legend yes right
you got to see I don't like you send me
a link to this idea yep and I was
listening to that
yep and after 20 minutes after it was
all said and done I said to myself who
the hell can sit and watch you know I
don't have time yeah you're been here
busy but what one of the things in the
end is said something about like you
like to motivate and inspire people to
do
yep and over the weekend I was in
Chicago as you know yeah I went to a
restaurant show came the McCormick
Center
I'm Balu giggling did will yes I put a
lot of miles there anyway so I was
walking through the aisle and I
second-day excellent and I stopped for
and at the one of the buses and and the
person behind nice guy was had some
spices
okay and that's how you have this year
okay I do cause I want to make sure I
ever found this one a name he wasn't
mine to tell right so I stopped there
and as I stopped there looking at you
know his the spices he looks like me and
looks at him and and in she looks at the
bear my name and and I see the guys
again I mean she spaces channel she said
they are joke while I were giving I said
yes my son she when I was thinking he
might - you crazy right
join me and in the two and a half
minutes he's telling me a story what he
used to be a chef and after here she
start following Gary on the Facebook and
Twitter you know and he read to all his
books all five there's four business
books one mind not write five books okay
she said he inspired him to start the
business and she said today she got a
very successful business he gave me a
number what eating is yes and she said
everything I got Everest I owe to you
son and a nice way and I do son without
me I didn't know I was a humble bottle
as I was here
right I know that's like and I was you
know if you took a picture with me and
you know I I actual very good and today
when I was listening to this blood makya
yeah it says you know yeah some blue
example will what you will you know how
do I feel for Dad given your background
very proud and being competitive of
course you know in our family you know
such a it's a rule right you have to be
a competitive or you can't play right I
still you know still very very proud and
yes you can't describe in words the
feeling how you feel about your own
child your own song your own daughter
yes it's it's unbelievable it's a that's
what I think any parents live for so
that's interesting that the reason I
really wanted to do this episode is more
and more you know small businesses
family businesses they reach out to me
they know the story I'm sort of the
waterworks I was I'm not long enough but
they know about and guys this is where I
can my interrupting from does Keith
Taylor and she's come here making this
guy you you're doing it for no I'm gonna
do I didn't ask before insecure I know
you I didn't even have never gone right
right
no but Keith what is that cool kill
company I can fight allergy spice IP you
did a really good job stop and Dad no no
no no no but I was you know she was I
can live in this great here it's a great
feeling for him you know what he feels
accomplished your again and it's a great
feeling why I was community base moment
yes was you know somebody will ask or
mommy ask actually
as highlight of the whole trip I said to
bump into this guy like yeah ticket I
love it
so you brought me over there you better
release brother there and the reason
I'll tell you why I bought a lot of this
personally I know you know know if you
have nothing to do with wine a lot no my
son all the son Gary as you know and I
have a G and of course I have a daughter
Elizabeth who always claims is right if
I couldn't get enough exposure I love
you Elizabeth Liz anyway the reason I
brought was that because Gary always
always was telling me that stop drinking
the same [ __ ] I mean a wine I shouldn't
say [ __ ]
so right stop drinking the same I'm a
creature of habit when I start a famine
cake I'm drinking the same bottle of day
your part the routine yes you mind if
somebody wants yeah somebody wants to
kill me will take impunity because I
will go to the same gas station same
same Dunkin Donuts same you know it's
unbelievable same supermarket I even
even it just hit me when I go to Costco
and I don't want to plug in Costco but
I'm plugging in your trunk I get donated
yeah no no no I park in the same spot in
the same spot with some I got it I would
park next to buddy
but the point is I park so far and it's
not like me but I would spark so far
away from the entrance but I would
always it's like it's mind boggling
your routine dye routine if I'm out of
my routines that's what drove everybody
watching on Instagram live right now put
everything into REM line is that we're
getting facebook facebook okay everybody
watching on Facebook right now uh which
one's the Facebook camera this one love
it Facebook start putting in your phone
numbers
dad this is now a call-in show people
gonna call unplug yeah boy yeah you you
almost said don't drink this
right and today I decided you were
surprised actually I'm stunned right
that I never drink Rosa
it was fun for me and dad about Rosa is
you know in the years that I was with
dad and definitely before I was with dad
in the store Rose they never sold and
I've never been before
no in the middle in the years that I was
with you and then obviously before me
for all those years were they never sold
right like Roseanne was not writing in
the US right we knew it like your per
second right there are non factors right
now now Ron Cey is a monster to monster
and the reason I picked this wine
because I had an opportunity to face a
boy and let me tell you something this
wine is absolutely phenomenal yeah and I
get up before we start at $12.99 a good
price
$12.99 for I mean and it's this time
with the year that's a perfect wife to
drink all right okay all right so we can
alter beaten white in the resin you know
red in the summer a little cooler with
Barbie a little bit yeah what else is
going on in the wine world towards the
liquor world that's interesting to you
before we get into the first question
well we can't ship wine well you can
ship
Kunie bomb grenade no it's good you know
that's such a penis another thing is
it's so stupid again like in the Ukraine
they disallowed young kids or whatever
to you know say blacks in the Facebook
or something so I feel in the wine
industry that's what's going on you like
communism for coming new floor right
yeah yeah exactly right yeah I'm not
complaining about that wine industry but
I'm complaining about the stupidity what
we're dealing or consumers bill you can
order a bottle of wine from leadership
to New York that's the most insane thing
I ever dealt with worse worst 15 years
of my life dealing with that [ __ ]
sucks
Ernie I'm so happy you're not in this
industry you have no idea every day yeah
I know we get up in the morning I'm
saying saying that I
it's really tough it's frustrating yeah
it's not pure capitalism that's right
yeah how about food stuff I know you're
killing it with Russian food mister
alright hello here we go what tonight
that's right we gotta get mad I'm do you
want to talk to us and I wish it was
Patrick you like that
Patrick doesn't Gary be enduring the
askgaryvee show with sasha be no way yes
yeah where are you from from Denver call
of it what's your question yeah follow
the concept for a lot of time and I mean
I kind of do a point right now a wind
balance patient with learning or needing
to pivot and rethink what you're doing
there's kind of here you talked about
knowing your truth and knowing what
you're driving for and staying on that
path but when do you know and what time
should you look for if you're if you're
needing to pivot change adjust so you
are you running a business yeah what
kind I'm doing a consulting business
around I see some of your pass without
engagement employees culture kind of
rethinking what a workplace needs to be
in a world of technology and the kind of
new reality so you're so you're trying
to figure out should you stay the course
and let the market come to you because
what you're selling is difficult to sell
because you believe in it so you want to
be patient or are you actually wrong or
is it too far away and she do pivot into
some other offers and features and
things of that nature is that correct
yes totally I mean I think you know that
is displace I do this is the bread and
butter but I feel like with a lot of
leaders of companies engagement
employees cultures number one is thought
but number two or three and actions so
I'm trying to figure out how to get into
that world how to kind of make it more
of a priority or is it just a lot of dog
for love dad what do you think about
when you think about your long career
when was it
stay the course because you believe in
some strategy category that you're
buying investing in liquor versus wine
advertising like when do you know that
you wanted to stay the course or when do
you know that you needed to try
something different or to get into
patterns I know for you I know your
story the best you know you were a very
early New Jersey newspaper advertiser in
a coop in the early 80s all right which
is a big breakthrough for you guys
created a coop you're selling at costs
in the newspaper that one
when did you know to add direct mail or
when do you try commercials when did you
say the course when did you change the
mix of your product in the store because
you felt Rosen was coming like how did
you make those decisions
well when honestly and I don't have to
give more credit to my son when I'm
thinking but he will take it I know when
Gary came to the business and he came at
the very young age at first he of course
was no factor she was making ice for
tada I don't even remember how under
faith right underpaid here
I was good at mechanics yeah so but then
he came to the business and again I
treasure this years what I spent working
with Gary when we used to remember that
travel back and forth ultimately what is
145 miles each way and that was the most
memorable moments wouldn't we used to
discuss business strategy let's link up
there's an article I wrote about exit 12
2014 that's on million that to me is
that is the foundation of our
relationship fan yeah the foundation
airily hand and to take Wine Library
what I came up with the name yes
absolutely true okay
did you Linda California well Coco all
the wineries work although wineries are
calling their sellers Wine Library no
I'll take you to the life or is that
equal why not I'll take you to the
library to pick up couple bottles of
wine and go for dinner that's where I
came up with the name of Wine Library
years after but that's that was quite
honestly all those great ideas than we
used to bounced off each other that's
when it's you know real start real
before it was just another liquor store
and that created really looking you so I
wanna make sure we interest question oh
I'm interviewing you a little bit about
your project so what you know but
Patrick's sitting here and you know it's
very old is Roger
I don't know how old are you Patrick I'm
31 ceremony on so Patrick's trying to
decide if you on the right what's the
balance between patients because I sell
patients you know I believe in didn't
have to pay you have to versus is he on
the right path is there something else
you should be putting innovation versus
patience have you thought about that
where have you not thought I know I did
okay you have some radiation that's from
say who says I'm a snow not Trump not
that that is more value you think the
patient's part is more value you have to
you know you have to believe and stick
to it to what you believe I mean that's
you know you can you can try something
can you know two days later or two years
later said okay that's your biggest
problem with I think you know that's
something I always yell about with our
employees you know I like you right at
your side yeah no question about I don't
mind if it denial and held on to talk a
lot of times so what he's worried about
mm-hmm as you're like thinking through
Pat you've listened I think the reality
is I'm a big believer in the following
you're not going to know the alternative
so you might have not dwell on it you're
not going to know right bro you're not
going to know if you waited too long
like a lot of people have bailed a month
before the thing they've worked on for
two years was about to go but they don't
know they don't know that Patrick
because they bailed in they're like ah I
was a waste of my two years yeah and I'm
100% and I'm not bailing on this and I
think I mean I'm pop committed believe
in patient it's just kind of fine-tuning
it or tweaking it and I guess maybe the
perception to you and I don't know
you're a firm believer in it if you
think that there's a market out there
was this yes I do I think culture and
the emotions and all the feelings of the
business there's a driving force of the
new economy I think culture my dad will
tell you as a kid as a child it mattered
to me it was intuitively in me at a very
young age it is emerged as an enormous
pillar and I think it will continue to
it will catch up my friend I agree with
you that that it's they talked about it
you said it you know first in what
about third and the way they execute
that exactly because they're full of
[ __ ] they say it oh that sounds good to
their employees but they don't want to
spend money on it but as operators like
me and others continue to get Fame and
awareness around trading on that that
will then people start realizing the
financial value of it I'm not doing it
I'm not doing it because of for kicks
and giggles now it's my natural demeanor
but it's still an ROI positive thing and
I think as decision-makers change over I
would say as decision-makers change over
from my dad's generation to my
generation and definitely the generation
below me this will become the pillar and
you're 31 you can grind it and survive
until you're 38 42 and really reaps the
massive financial benefits of being a
leader in the space for a decade
yeah and it's kind of interesting you're
right I think that when I talk to people
there's about a director level and below
then everybody gets it and see that once
you go above there and people take
ownership of the job that just gets
scared of change and I kind of pulled on
it and push back yeah you hey Cheech yes
right like a big bust but to your cloth
absolutely my credit you know who I want
at Waterman to not only spire you you
actually drilling me to try to do
different things just like breaking
different one yeah imagine you know
happen within 18 20 year old me in the
car from 45 minutes back afford my food
if you had any like I mean runs a
blazing mmm I appreciate Patrick that's
right that I think I think you know who
I want calling Facebook if you're
watching right now if you're either the
father of the month mother or the son or
the daughter in a business that is
struggling with the Khoa relationship I
will say here you know it scares me it
rocks me to the bone of how much I
didn't appreciate the ear cover that my
dad gave me I stand on his shoulders
because he let me stand on his shoulders
like he didn't suppress me when I think
about the liquor business couple my
dad's friends unfortunately one good
friend had passed away not too long ago
like my way or if
100% my dad was part of a generation
there was a five to seven guys are the
biggest stores and three or four of them
had their sons go into the business and
it didn't work now do I think I was more
towns in the sense of course I would but
but my dad one bar but my dad gave me
major air cover 2x I always believed in
you
a hundred percent I knew that wrong yeah
from today when you used to rip the
flowers from our neighbor globe with
Maris and sell it to hurt
that's what's blown my mind I mean you
know I didn't I wouldn't have that what
they have two hoots what they did but
you did she used to go and her name is
Gayle right yeah I remember this game
John yes and Sikkim Joe and the talents
of flowers and they knew but that he was
a little kid I just play along
take your advantages where they are not
for this there they are captain nope
British Columbia Canada Alaric big
hockey huge he's not gonna answer his
phone could be devastating
dad one thing one thing I talked a lot
about killer he's finished sorry our key
dad one thing I talk a lot about is how
much he works right like my work ethic
completely inspired by um mom the way
she works the house but much more you um
you know we really didn't hang out and I
think you know from you got water you
have dialed is not in service
we don't need thing to talk about what I
got fired the one time for what
listening time a simple movie for Helen
oh sure they will character go ahead
tell me I mean D arias for two hours off
another day off let them ask to leave
early for high school party you know
when you graduate high school people
have parties I ask on a Saturday to
leave it five instead of seven pm right
right and I worked every summer day
these are like this is Miller job of
northward I asked to leave at five
instead of seven one day and we believe
the house of seventh open the store so
seven to five you know we're going to
find out later
you know two hours early hanging up on
this one hold on I gotta tell us sorry
this is how hardcore my dad is I asked
to leave two hours early on one day for
the whole summer
he looked me dead in the face and said
you're not committed to the business
you're fired
she came home I think it was crying and
of course he's more than I had to give
them all to know and then I was I went
from crying because I cried to smiling
because I actually didn't work the next
day and since I've been working my whole
high school life I was like wait a
minute is really great this is
interesting given what laughs we're here
laughter little anything I did on I'm
not yet this is right right and I go
what I can joke
this was playing rent an Avengers yes
and so I was like this is amazing
and then my Tina my dad doesn't really
green come to apologize he just walked
into my room the next day he goes you
couldn't come to work I'm like all right
it's really what happened to but uh
Gareth talking about me being top guy
you should ask him about his parking
tickets in Boston that was Elvis never
not a story anyone knows so in Boston my
junior year on Comm Ave there was
nowhere to really really Park so it was
super hard so I just would park in
places I ended up with like six but he
they for job guys he is what is like a
local harmon when you open all the
parking tickets for its got to build 100
parking tickets clicking the end and he
she came to me and being a tough father
you know what everybody's things I paid
all the techie you're only top on the
outside right super salade paid all the
tickets that's right oh my gosh and what
about the ten thousand dollar club bill
doc we're not going to do that
we kind of short that story's not coming
out I'm sure you member liamail coming
out now this isn't success and begin to
question reward yeah gets too out of
control
quite an electrician oh boy what do we
got come on yeah yeah okay
next get anything today
well your honor diving [ __ ] here we
got to Robin you say Rob yeah rabbit my
father
okay so we've robbed a Nick Sonora line
in New Jersey we're in Jersey
you're located a man go right off the
interstate Eric oh boy yeah we know
silver belt awesome man how are you guys
Gary here any better there'd be two of
us so we're fortunate actually if we're
any better I'd have to sit on my hands
to keep from clapping thanks for it
that's awesome that's awesome guys what
can we help you with so Gary this is
we're just our questions get a boy on
there is for you are we on the right
track
we're building safety business under New
Jersey and we do education so we're
focused on building our business taking
a bigger already doing space book as
we're doing we're going to be moving on
the Instagram ads we're getting our
website updated we just want to know if
we're on the right track we have 15
instructors teaching all over the state
we're on in about 200 classes a year so
I mean what else can we be doing better
we we have all the multimedia tools to
tell our story online and I mean I think
I think which is - it's really just two
or three of us in the office right now
then enter got 200 pounds a year so I
mean it every on the right track well so
I think I think the question becomes
what where do you want the finish line
to be on that track you have to work
backwards
if you're on the right track or not
right how old is he how old are you so
I'm 24 like that is pretty 57 young crew
oh my gosh so I think I think the
question is the track right like when
you say are we on the right track
are you asking are we spending our money
in the best optimal places to maximize
our short-term growth yeah my garrison
my dad's bearing is that yeah yeah I
mean not so I think you know listen I
think I think Dad did dad here can talk
that's the advantage of having my dad
here I think the question becomes are
you guys Nick are you are you in a
dynamic where you guys like you believe
in this if dad are you looking for the
obvious black and white ROI like what
whether it's friction or optimism like I
assume that's the question that's the
cliche cliche question right which is is
the ROI in this paying the dividends I
think to my dad's credit here there's a
story that is so insane having my dad
here
my dad approved a Wine Spectator year by
four I came to my dad I said dad I want
to buy this spot in the Wine Spectator
magazine which don't forget you guys all
know me I love trading attention and I
felt the entire attention of the wine
business was in the Wine Spectator on
this one page where they had pictures of
the labels and the scores and there was
an ad spot on the right and the ad the
ad for the yearly cost of the ad was so
much money it was basically almost equal
to our profit the year before well the
actual it was to the exact numbers
$192,000 what I sent the check out on my
personal accounts to marvin shenkin the
one stupid medium had the cash line we
didn't have the cash law and I believe
well I believe in my son from day one
you know but that's not what I did
I you know I always I always willing not
only because I Gary I always was willing
and correct me for you know I always was
willing to invest in the business
business always came before personal
personal yeah you know yeah you didn't
buy [ __ ] right
you have no education for sure oh you
guys what dollars into the business into
the
so I think guys I think the thing that
you know what what's the mortar Nick
what's your that's your name and your
what's your dad's name later Robert I
think the question is I'd love for you
to answer here are you guys trying to
like what's the scenario here are you
trusting your son like spending these
marketing dollars in these new
environments and you're trying to get a
grasp on what the ROI is you are
absolutely correct right there because I
don't know [ __ ] when it comes to
Facebook and Instagram and anything like
that and I'm trying to get a grasp on I
get it so unfortunately I can't get up
release this Robert right as a father
you will know better than anybody if and
I don't want to sound like it's this in
all the business you you have to for
yourself you have to say is my son
capable to grow the business or not
that's a very simple question and it's a
very simple answer nobody can answer
this question for you not even my genius
son who sit next to me because you have
to know if you son is capable and he
going to take your business to the next
level or you son no disrespect to the
schlemiel that's it so it's a very you
know cut liners with black and white and
that's it you have to really hang up
you're going to you're going to the
bathroom and you know look in the mirror
and said yeah I believe in my son and
I'm going to invest or you walk in and
say you know what I I don't think he's
capable to do that to me that Robert I I
agree with that because the beauty of
having a family business is that you're
playing forever right the big the big
wake up call for me when I got into
corporate America is that my dad and I
for all the things we agreed on all the
things we disagreed on thank god we
loved each other just enough more than
we love the business which allowed us to
keep a relationship but ninety nine
percent of our energy was always about
the business for the long term and so I
think I think dad's shooting it right
Robert I think I think you know it's
funny I'm looking at a lot of my team
members
I just make binary decisions if I think
they can do it or not and then I let
them win fail tweak I think it's a I
think you bet against your I think the
real answer rubber is you bet on your
belief on Nick's capabilities or whoever
else could be driving this to a level
that you can afford clearly in hindsight
I was so confident I just thought who
wouldn't bet on me I was blind but in
hindsight my dad using his own personal
money putting back into the business to
make an advertising bet is the ultimate
belief and what I was I'm sure there's a
lot of mom and dads out there they're
watching there might be willing to spend
20% of the profits as a bet because they
don't know yet
I did a lot of things from 0 to 22 to
give my dad confidence not just after
intuition I came in and did things that
we had a we love us $80,000 spent on the
Jets [ __ ] billboard cooler vocalist
a little warfare Cardinals I need to be
on the sideline that's a macro that's
right I Robert I think it's a binary
question I think dad's exactly right too
many people ticky tack it I think it's a
binary question of what's the allocation
of dollars that you want to support
Nick's vision and then whatever that is
write it off if it if he fails because
you know that Nick will learn from that
and take it to the next step a bet on
what you can afford to lose mentally as
much as financially and I think you'll
be in the right position makes sense we
are at a position where we're crushing
it right now based on the previous
year's income and we definitely need to
do more how does that [ __ ] with Facebook
or anything so my question to you is
will this Facebook and Instagram be able
to take us higher use of it what are you
spending on your what are you spending
your money on now Google Adwords what
tune of about 15 grand a year um so and
what is that creating for you is
creating
you know tons and tons of these leaves
which ultimately the people come in and
take our voting safety classes over the
other companies we're actually aren't
even using the right so Robert here's
the thing that I would answer I would
say most likely no however if Nick is
good enough to produce a video and spend
$3,000 on amplifying it against
employees of or the target segment
because he figured that out his $3,000
video is $3,000 ad spent on Facebook and
his thousand dollar video cost on a
local production company could bring you
the value of spending fifteen million
dollars on Google if he hits it right
and it creates virality or he could
completely put that five thousand
dollars directly in the trash if it
doesn't okay
so if you're a conservative player my
intuition is no if you're on the pure
offense and you know look Nick Richard
uh I'm sorry uh I love Robert
ayuh you know I view you at 57 as young
I don't know where your head's at I know
a lot of 57 year olds who want to play
golf for the rest of the letters and I
know a lot of 50 my dad will die at his
desk at Wine Library that's just money
in the bank and I will do the same
wherever my desk is so you know to me
betting on Nick for a year even if it
goes to complete zero isn't a deathblow
in the marathon that you might be
running if you're trying to maximize
dollars right now because you want to
buy a beach house in South Carolina and
golf in two years you may stay
conservative because you want the
dollars we're going to need a bigger
boat again a brother so look I think if
you're if you're running the marathon
I think risk is actually practical does
that make sense it absolutely is and I'm
not afraid to take it and run I'll tell
you the other thing there's nothing
better than sticking it to your 24-year
old punk son when he thinks he knows
everything
and he goes and throws $15,000 in the
trash I reminded oh [ __ ] like that all
I'm sure Nick I promise you in Reverse
there's nothing like telling people all
this crazy [ __ ] like let's have a
website let's do email and not everybody
sure but you get the support of your dad
and if you deliver it becomes the
ultimate relationship in life
absolutely thank you so much for taking
our goal yeah really good luck you guys
take care right along to me that's like
that's why I wanted you on the show
that's cool that's us that's it and
that's real and dad that is happening
for I mean I get Milly you know my life
I will get millions I get tens of
thousands a year you know people
emailing me about like my dad won't do
this my mom let me do this my son wants
to do this the thought family business
dynamics right like you had three kids
I worked hard core with you rose Liz
came for a summer got fired never came
back
well sugar AJ dusted shelves for an hour
and never came back
right right so you've had the gamut of
it it's a lot of stuff right that's a
lot it's a lot of baggage we dealt with
a lot of stuff right hmm but the end of
the day what was law father and sons was
first and that was liquor and a lot of
people don't have that and that's the
quarter Charlotte's not going to work a
hundred percent better got anyone anchor
and her prompt 'men from - Riviera
emotion City NJ New Jersey New Jersey
kick it up to the father-son dynamic
it's a Jersey Jersey anyway hello Edgar
this is Gary Vee you're on the
askgaryvee show with sasha Vaynerchuk oh
my gosh that is so awesome
well we're gonna have you right where
you from her I'm promoting sending dirty
oceans lead motion what's up my man
what's your question
oh it's a very simple question um
I'm currently working with two family
businesses one of the construction
business better than the cleaning
business and then we want to meet
merging together by you know just you
know just recycling our customers
throughout that what my question is I
don't know like if I deserve to be paid
more than I'm getting paid right now for
doing the work that I'm doing I'm
handling all the social media
advertising for a company I do all the
office paperwork back off like after
hours and I do a lot of selling as well
and I don't know I just feel like since
it's my standing I don't I don't I don't
think I had the authority should be able
to ask them for money more money than I
already get so who owns the to other
businesses the two businesses one well
the one is under my name and the other
one is owned by my uncle uncle and who
would make the decision if you were to
get paid more
Oh my uncle
and yes my Uncle Ben degree and so
what's happening do you feel that you're
slightly underpaid grossly underpaid
like what's your what's your truth
well I only made right now 23,000
working with the foot we make a lot more
than that nice as I was I'm in the
background and I you know I kind of want
to get a little bit more how older I
just I'm 21 years old
one young look I think we've ever seen
hesitation for me my dad is the true
answer is every family dynamic has their
own spiel right
have you ever broached the subject
lightly with your uncle yeah all right
now right now it's up in the air he said
how much ski you want to get paid and
I'm in the position that I don't want to
over charge and I really know how to
charge my family I don't know if I
should charge my family I love my family
that one I want the business to grow
that's my main focus by also you know
like I am working a lot
are you close was your uncle yes I'm
very close my uncle and your uncle have
children yes yes two children
tip of one is 22 another one is 18 are
they in the difference or either
businesses mm-hmm not really well that's
a lie today that's a data point uh-huh
so look here's what I would say I think
that the number one thing is
communication but when you're not
talking danger comes oh yeah right
when I would say when you know my dad
we're at the best we were talking right
when we're at our worst we were keeping
it into ourselves and we were letting
things fester and bother us right so I
would say when I hear even I don't know
you from Adam I've known you for four
seconds in my life I can tell you're
often you're coming at this in such a
good way you're like I love my family
like like you know so I would say couple
things to you you're 21 years old right
you're obviously not making a lot of
money
do you need money is a really
interesting question do you feel like
your happiness on the weekends or
vacations is limited because if you had
more money you'd have more fun like do
you want to save more money like where
are you at with money with $23,000 he's
making them nothing right yeah but let's
talk about for a second where where are
you with your relationship with money
well right now all I have to do is just
give my mom some some money so you know
we get they rent and whatnot but uh
other than that I really don't need much
money other than gas and getting getting
food perfection that's about it it's
just I don't know it's really but that's
a great question I don't know let me ask
you a question it's easier to ask me
then who's your uncle given all the
dynamics if I like like just shooting
the [ __ ] like what would what would
freak you out happy like what would make
you super happy while factoring in all
the things that are running through your
mind which I love because I love your
vibe I wish you were my nephew I would
do real damage with you like weird where
is we're gonna go where is where is your
mind set right now what would be awesome
what would you like to go to open it
like it I were able to you know just pay
like my rent punctured
and we like we're constantly over spoken
in our apartment right now we have all
my aunt and my company coming to live
here for this summer and people would
just have like a bigger place just so we
get all this funky along well much how
not another great wedding that number
what's that number I am really good but
if I just made at least 2,000 extra
month I beat another 12,000 if I made
thirty five thousand dollars of rain Oh
Frankie not I'm telling you pretty happy
I'm telling you have to be a hangout the
forum was Gary you call empire and
Sascha call your uncle poor man ice
glass of red wine say that we reserved
or rose eggs away tell them that you're
bleeding out of your eyeballs and you
always will for the family business and
then it would be game-changing for you
if you could go to $35,000 a year here's
the good news my friend if you do what
my dad and I are saying right now you
will win because either a you will get
the 35,000 or B you will have a data
point on how your uncle reacts to that
request and third thing if your uncle
said no to you ask them to call us back
no no I'm gonna leaven 3376 triple zero
five that's my rider a phone number
Sascha Vaynerchuk right right
I mean do you can I ask you a question
cuz I like bring value on the show your
honor are you going to do it were you
too scared to ask tell me the truth I
look scared at why I don't want to see
vaulted as a leach company you know like
it fit business I want someone who tries
Elysee like I already like you know
doing the business actually that's like
that's fun for me first one like and
like I am getting paid you know and
usually yeah what you're not getting
paid enough
so here's what I'm at I know what you do
but it doesn't dollar I make a shoes get
paid more here's what I'm saying I would
say that you need to ask your your uncle
that this is the number you're striving
for you'd like it right now because you
feel the work ethic and the results that
you're driving is driving
towards that and ask him if he agrees
and if not what does what has to happen
for you to get there because that's what
you need to do to provide for your mom
and all these people that are coming in
to move in with you right do we get
benefits or decide to the pager order do
we get benefits like medical or all
right now we only been a business trip
for like three four years coming up four
years now but around our town everybody
they carry like we eat grown in like
Maddie like a numbers way but like
people see like they know of us and they
know our work ethic and they just they
just get much business and we've been
able to grow pretty pretty fast over
these four years that's why I know that
I'm able to get this one isn't it
brother listen to me you're not going to
you're going to lose you're eventually
going to crack and start hating your
uncle so you might as well do the right
thing by your uncle and have this
conversation right right absolute 1000%
got it you're doing your uncle a favor
by having this question otherwise you're
going to resent him mm-hmm and it's
gonna be an issue right absolutely
you understand right so don't don't even
make this about you do the right thing
by your uncle and have this conversation
mm-hmm got it oh good yeah okay I'm
gonna call right now call him right now
and I want you to tweet me at Gary B and
tell me you called you not to give me
details just prove to me that you call
an unsocial because if you don't I'm
going to send it the hundreds of
thousands of people that give a [ __ ]
about this show and we're gonna bother
you until you suffocate well I don't I
don't have a Twitter but I can send you
miss Dunn is great respect ordered on
video
I love it good luck man let me know
there's an email to Gary [ __ ] media
with an update already there so much
you're welcome it's cool right dad this
is really like she got it took a whirl
on the big without knowing anything you
know but you know this one look is right
and I just feel it's an honest and I'm
pumped to say this publicly
nobody asked you
poor necessity I get it I mean to pay
rent I get it I get it people on welfare
get paid more
that's not happy with the price point
I'm not absolutely remember it baby
shine you see J we have to pay much
nobody job I don't we were laughing I'm
like I was thinking the first time I
brought our adductors me too you know 20
was seniors the first time I really
really started here was around 27 28
like you know you know when you're
investing you're investing but he's the
middle sensation and his name uncle
knuckle could swab not I get it the
different Walter's mother yes and now
unfortunately what you'll want you write
like you know we know us by like when
you go out in the world unfortunately
there's a lot of uncles who take care of
their net world water draw your dad's
pecans and that is the other songs you
know what else add without what other
wisdom talk to talk to the kids for a
minute talk to the 20 year olds who want
not the given a good point but they
guess them good actually they're all
here to but there's a lot we're watching
like what what are the kid what
advantages do you think you had as an
immigrant advantages oh I do tell me I
never really a nationally recognized the
investiture I had a dream just like a
what the Luther King's can if I had a
dream yeah I don't want to talk about
your dream a little bit actually know
what let me ask some questions that
maybe I mean I've asked you so much [ __ ]
45 minutes I did most of the talking
not even our in there you know right dad
what you come to America economy [ __ ]
you're this distant great-uncle was a
liquor store New Jersey right mmm
like yours goes your stash first cousin
you live in Queens you're driving a car
and you can tell the story about your
first car where you didn't know have yet
a pump gas you just ran a girl in do
both male car that's my father first
cousin gives you a car very nice letter
very nice of her and I never forgot to
cite a real good core and
maxillary I'm going to see her at the
wedding we're going to see her the way
yes good and I used to drive from a twin
school Clearbrook you guys don't know
like this is when you were still working
high structure that's Turnpike yep your
advantage I'm clear book Turnpike I can
multitask out here right exit 8a on a
Turnpike and unfortunately this car that
was a car Pinta you know yeah of course
man I was the single biggest buyer at
the hardware store for oil because the
car was purchased at the auction and the
motor had to haul so every so many miles
like 20 miles I had to stop and I used
to care in the trunk I used to carry
cases of oil
10:38 and I used to pour in engine and
drive I mean that's what it was fun for
me years even to get up at 4:00 and talk
to me got between the dream I always
want I was competitive that's you know
that's what's real also all about onion
I was competitive if I want to you know
have a nice house I want to have a
business I would I want him there's no
sign of all the scattered dream big
dreams
actually the resistor I don't know if
you know when we first came with settled
in prints at the apartment studio
apartment was was you mom was pregnant
to their part in one room and we were at
an organization called highest who
sponsor for the family to come and I had
a cousin who said still around first
cousin my mother
door Rita and we were walking she we
were looking at Queens Boulevard and at
that time and interest
it was Alexander's I need a store a big
department store like you know Target
today and let's call our attenders and I
saw that look at me working actually
like makes is right and I said one day
I'm going to have something like that
and she looks at me and she start
laughing but then why you built a
three-story yeah how is your signal and
ride a just ones that we really need a
bride
but you're like [ __ ] I need to be
venture amendment that's right yeah
that's that's what listen
land of opportunities if you want to
accomplish anything or is not a better
place to live and not that better place
to be and I left lever Roma country
where I never think what's suppressed
that the communist country and you know
everybody should be equal
you know and you know it was [ __ ] up
yeah yeah didn't work I remember the
biggest things that impacted me was a
you and mom thought that if somebody was
fifty or sixty they were very old
because people were so fundamentally
miserable under communism I don't like
that the other night yeah people were
you know sixty people used to die
because I'm just miserable yeah not
coming back here's parents right yep
they came from Russia we read it right
not a good place to be today then mmm
tough doesn't it sure does Jr hey wait
wait would you my name is junior and
your ballot of Dallas yes sir usually
you want to go to hell right yeah I mean
you got shot back in 1980 I feel like I
came back to life I was born in 82
respect
my man how are you I'm doing great thank
you very very much for the foot
challenge made a little bit of money on
eBay also a little bit of money on
Facebook ads so thank you very much for
that first and foremost you must watch
it
Sasha I had a question mainly for you
I hope my kind of going bad here among
young dad and um I guess trouble is the
work-life balance thing I know that you
guys kind of don't really answer
questions because of the context you
know and we you know there it's just
different for different people but how
how did you get through those times when
you were you know working all the time
not really spending a whole lot of time
with the kiddos and then how did you I
guess establish that relationship later
on well let me tell you something
looking back and I'm 61 halal in 63
that's crazy
is that true yeah you are holy [ __ ]
yeah 66 looking back at screen I have
progressed laka let's work out for me
but I did not go to any games gotta play
baseball but a little leak and all that
I didn't go to I think go to anything
good I mean at one point in school
everybody was under oppression what my
wife does not have a husband that's true
yeah okay it was people were talking
about and saying that she made up you
know not even or something
because I work every hour and you know
what looking back again luckily for me
for the family things worked out with
the kids but I have a lot of regrets
what I didn't allocate at least a little
bit of time I'm completely on yeah I
completely well in and and I was always
worried about people's going to steal a
limited or something
from my personal experience you can
sleep in the goddamn business if people
wants to steal they're going to steal
why do you think that well not real
quick well we're I'm going to deviate
because I think this might help a couple
people do you think that you know I mean
was the biggest thing you instilled in
me at 14 15 16 this fear that employees
were going to steal it was number one
right do you feel like that's a complete
correlation to being in Soviet Russia
where everybody must I have an employer
who why would boss work there oh [ __ ]
people snap money oh yeah I can people
steal yeah but 90 percent of people here
steal time all day they're not like
feeling like but like that's not what I
mean I don't mean that people people
stole under my watch every day let alone
like under your watch every day no you
were obsessed with it do you believe
that that was a byproduct of the Soviet
system
yeah that's said I have a lot to do was
I thinking where I can't it came from
and my upbringing
that's definitely half a lot so what he
telling Jo and Jerry Jerry I some real
quick I apologize dad er I don't think
like when people hear my stories I don't
think they really realize it we're an
extreme family in like my dad came to
one baseball we're not normal time my
dad came to one baseball game in my
entire life I could remember it vividly
it was an all-star game I pinched I'm
super pumped came with my who passed
away uncle Misha you know they both came
I was super pumped that is literally the
only member of the CLE circle at the
graduation my daughter had in high
school in high school okay you know in
87 they used to pull
parents to the podium right oh no you
know what this was was when she was
senior when she's cheerleading right
earlier and they were calling the
parents I'm asking Ryan's come out with
my daughter yeah at my daughter's right
Elizabeth and I was in the Air Force my
black was there was my younger son AJ
right and I how old he was he was at the
time ten ten so as I :
mr. and mrs. Van joke right and tomorrow
had AJ and she's dragging him to the
podium and she didn't want to go I mean
you know Natalie looking back at this
you know TJ got the benefit oh hey I got
the benefit she was a youngest one and
after so many years working hard and all
that
I think Irene and they are in the
business of course we have to give him
credit you know and highlight like she
doesn't get enough I start going to his
games
Angelo Joe yeah and let me tell you
something it's you have to allocate and
I don't know percentages I don't know
how much time but you have to listen I'm
given I'm given a lot of credit to my
daughter Laura Elizabeth perfect
her name was Elizabeth as well she makes
Gary to spend time with kids on the
weekend
Masashi she's and you know what in the
beginning I was kind of it wasn't a
foreign to me and then I said to myself
but it's very important and the right
and that's the right thing to do so GI
okay I'm for you are you having a
problem with yourself internally or with
your partner oh it's a little bit above
but mainly it's me internally
just kind of feeling guilty about it I
didn't try to get through the hard times
if there's me a piece of advice that you
have just you know getting through that
like guilt oh yeah yeah oh you're
talking you're talking to two men who
have zero guilt for putting in the time
at work I promise you can share his DNA
there was never one day in the first 18
years of my life not one day you up
learners and fans to my dad's credit we
live in 2017 now in nineteen eighty and
ninety there was no conversation of
work-life balance there was no pressure
on the father to be at the game some
fathers did it but that wasn't a
conversation you never heard of that my
dad went through my entire childhood not
one day having guilt I promise you that
truth I know it I'll tell you why I
don't either
yes I spend way more time with my kid
I'm going there right now like me and
Tyler looking at each other and now he's
stressed because I have to go darling
well he's crass because we have decided
to go with something and I can't thing
that I wanna go I don't want to be late
and I'm so much fun with you but I have
a kid thing that I'm going to right now
I right now I will go to his more
functions than my skip school that my
dad did in his career but I will tell
you this if I don't go to a single
mother one from right now to my kids
graduating I will feel zero get because
I know like my dad knows that our intent
was in the right place my dad grew up in
a place and in the world and he's old
school for old school my dad 63 going on
630 in his demeanor he's old-school
right you look at a little [ __ ] here she
ya handshake right right
so the Connor you understand I won't be
my dad felt no guilt and I'll tell you
why junior he judged himself within
himself and if he knew his intent was to
provide for the family
and that with his role especially what
he knew his wife was way better that
emotional intelligence and relieving the
kids and he was better at doing the
thing and I feel the same way I know
that everything I decide I'm trying with
the best of my ability Jared you have to
try the best in Ken you
can't let the outside world not Sasha or
Gary Vaynerchuk not your partner not
your parents not a magazine not a
podcast judge you you just have to do
the best you can
mm-hmm did we already pushing again does
that make sense
that's definitely okay so guess what if
tomorrow you feel like you have to go to
the thing go to the thing and if the
next day you feel like you got to go to
the meeting go to the [ __ ] meeting
stop judging yourself right no question
about all right thank you Gary
you gotta brother let's suck that your
mom was going to - sorry about that
got a little clumsy she loved it Jinxy
really loved it
so listen talk to me real quick on
wrapping this up work-life balance is
that everybody's top of mind listen it's
a whole different society to a whole
different generation it's a whole
different approach to things and balance
I never had a gap in balance
I never had a balance I mean I'm extreme
I anything I do I don't have a good
balance anything I do and I'm trying to
change myself but you know Helen I went
to Chicago no joke it's not a joke for
my dad to go to a business meeting in
Chicago right it's like more such
pattern breaking that it seemed no
question about what stop month I enjoy
it and I'm trying to do the right thing
for again for the business trying to do
a little diverse diverse fight trying to
real you know do a
new things because while the arrogance
is on single on and he is not able to
fit ever sinking for 28 hours day so I
have to you know and I'm not ready to
lose sell retire or quit or anything
like that so I'm looking for
opportunities I'm getting a little bit
more involved in the food business I
told you about the food distributor is
already like my dad is become hardcore
in selling Russian food not hard for
please dad I hope you're wrong about
that yeah I'm plump so listen you're
dominating you're right I'm not
dominating you're dominating the Russian
oil business dad no no guys please
dominating the Russian food business in
the jerseys are you putting people out
of business I'm not putting any what is
please please it's not smart people in
the wine industry hate me I don't need
anybody to hate me alright dad question
of the day my question yeah you get to
ask the question of the entire
vaynernation
what's the question you ask a question
not a statement of the day which is
where you've historically been a
question what would you like to answer
how do we you know and I get all this
shows what in your wine library were and
guarantee doesn't like you to get to
politics and I'm going to try to not to
and I'm going to be very politically
correct if I can't like just like our
president okay how do we solve that
terrorism problem in the world because
what happened day before yesterday
yeah right thanks Esther Manchester as
you know young kids young little kids
and this [ __ ] lunatics blow not
innocent what would do was
Society you know it's accepting
everybody it's not affecting just
America not perfected ever but it Russia
Europe everybody's attention how do we
get this people to senses do you know
what you know that my shows categorizing
businessman in politics all absorb give
a business question it's a girl either
clarified before I ask the question well
you know you know we what normally
happens as we end the show I give you a
kiss and go damn next time would be
really great if you didn't do the
politics that I've been doing just bear
that was a fairly war that was much less
teeth than normal from you that's a
general question you're a virgin
so yeah the time I have a great company
to the office the wine is great I can't
go off it's very impressive I would like
Neal Burnett to come to visit one you
really want you to come here know our
union like yeah I didn't speak someone
months may have I yeah but but Graham
good terms but you've had two separate
periods where you guys didn't speak for
appetite for fun right five years
because of character I love you dad
are you thinking because you keep asking
questions we'll keep answering them
and I'll have a little more
[Music]